moe williams literally left nobody knew
where he went and then came back and
played in game five of the nba finals
yeah it was important to us dante jones
played in the finals like i remember
vividly coach going dante i need you and
he rips his stuff off he hasn't played a
minute dante jones
big intro game six integral is that the
worst integral
integral integral there we go that's a
good word
intrical
[Music]
what up guys today welcome to full body
with my sort of good friend kevin love
as the wines get darker the question's
going to get deeper let's first open
this moet up i got this moet honestly
because i'm pretty proud of you man this
is what you're 14. i'll be heading into
14 next year you know got to celebrate
each year i love it this year's been
wild to say the least
let's start like this like growing up in
lake oswego oregon like when did you
discover like that basketball was your
thing didn't you play baseball too
played baseball played little league i
was uh a pitcher but
you know my my true love was with
basketball my dad played in the nba
right looked up to my dad as my hero he
had me on the phone when i was young
with you know guys like connie hawkins
he showed me jerry west who he played
with dale goodrich happy harrison elmore
smith blocked 17 shots in the game elvin
hayes earl the pearl wes unsell who i'm
named after my middle name wesley some
of the greatest of all time so
basketball was always it being there for
14 years there's a lot of guys actually
from portland who are just hoopers like
terence ross i was like i saw him play i
was like this guy has no business being
in high school like he has no business
like he's a pro you can see it right
there so
your transition from high school to
ucla like why ucla what was it about
that stupid school that you liked and
also like what was it like playing with
russell westbrook in your stack team and
i think you guys may or may not have won
once
but i don't know i didn't do the
research but good did you guys win a
national championship when you were
there uh yeah we did because we have
it's a better school so we had to let
somebody else win no i understood i
ended up picking ucla because going back
to my dad for a second morningside high
school my dad's assistant high school
coach was jim harris
so we started going to the games all my
family from southern california we would
go to paulie pavilion and watch jim
anderson those teams play it was amazing
to see because you know there was great
pros throughout the pac-10 and i always
thought it'd be great to play close to
home or close to family
and my top two schools at the end of the
day were north carolina which is crazy
roy williams i mean
finally yeah hung it up yeah it's crazy
he after all that time so those were my
top two schools for me it made the most
sense two back-to-back final fours we
ended up making to a third straight
final four loss to memphis which all
four number one seeds kansas and north
carolina were in there and that was an
incredible year but didn't get the job
done russell and i left and we were the
fourth and fifth pick did you see the
evolution of russell westbrook from then
who is just this like
downhill runner just attacking iraq to
this guy that's now completely
like crushing the nba so it was crazy
russ and i we had known each other and i
know he had come from losing her high
school he didn't dunk until he was a
junior in high school what which is
crazy his senior year jordan farmar
ended up going to the league so opened
up a spot at ucla i think his other
school might have been creighton oh wow
russ ends up at ucla doesn't play much i
think maybe 11 minutes his freshman year
i remember watching i think they played
kansas and he had a really great game
but really just defensive player and
then
just make some plays happen on offense
but he wasn't a primary focus on either
side of the ball so fast forward the
summer when i got there first time i saw
him in the men's gym and this was at the
time when like kg was in there paul
pierce kobe would come in
and i can remember russ just kind of
taking it off the top of the glass
you know coming down surveying the court
you know kind of cross-grained into the
lane you know kind of spun back and went
up with his left hand and was like top
of the square and finished and i thought
wow
he's going to be special and the four he
ended up the best thing i think that
that happened to him and maybe even our
team was that
unfortunately darren carlson had an mcl
sprint in his knee ross had to play
point guard
so he had to handle the ball he had to
guide the team he had to run the team
once he moved
to that shooting guard position and i
was able to outlet to both those guys
those guys were able to we're all able
to play off each other lucan balmoute
josh ship i mean we had a number of
players on that team that could really
play that's a squat that's the squad
we're at the red hook winery and so this
is abe schoener jamesport vineyard savvy
on blanc they make a really good sb it
has melon notes it's refreshing so we
talked about rust as transformation we
want to talk about your transformation
right you went from
a big boy yeah okay with a full chin
strap yep
two all of a sudden you're on like the
esp and the body issue how was that
evolution and then like you were
a walking bucket you were getting 20 and
20 as the old you but then your
efficiency was still there and a lot of
guys can't do that yeah well first i'll
say this like i've had my fair share of
injuries in my career but i was looking
at being 270 pounds and thinking that
one's sustainable right right at six
eight and a half like i i it just wasn't
sustainable for me to be that heavy i'm
thinking i can't play 82 games i can't
play four games in five nights i can't
go play dallas
fly back and play back to back being
that heavy
and i think i got away with it because i
was in my early twenties but i knew that
long term longevity wise and being able
to stay in the league especially with
and my dad had the presence of mine he's
like
you got to be able to shoot the ball
yeah i know you have the touch i know
you have the capability i know you have
the skill set it was the same thing with
you being a stretch five right right if
you don't have that today you might not
see the floor there's very few
big men the pulse ups are 50 down in the
last six years yeah i just think the
evolution of the game is like there are
more
big men that can shoot and stretch the
floor than there are true point guards
no and if you're able to stretch the
floor it's it's just such an asset for a
team especially
knowing how hard it is to guard those
guys it's impossible but i think
what my father understood and what i
understood was that the game was
changing yeah yeah and it was becoming a
pace in space type league when i retired
from basketball i realized that wine was
my dream outside of the dream and i also
realized i had to do it my way by
creating my own wine label chosen family
wines and in this segment we're going to
dive into my guest dreams brought to you
by porsche
so was there more pressure being a
lineage kid
than you think the other kid like being
you know no offense the white guy you're
athletic but you're not like you don't
jump out the gym
like most of your highlight videos where
you throwing outlet passes right and
getting rebounds like but for it's like
how does that like growing up that way
how did that motivate you i always talk
about like we play in the best
league in the world because it's so
diverse even dating back to my childhood
my dad taking me having the presence of
mind and understanding because it was
the same way with him he grew up in
englewood california went to morningside
high school
and played against
you know a lot of teams that were
predominantly black and he knew that if
he was going to get better he had to
play against the best and you know the
league has been built on the shoulders
of of black players right so he knew
that taking myself and at the time it
was northeast portland injecting me into
you know where jefferson high school
where grand high school lincoln high
school pil schools
were in the inner city he said you have
to play there
in order to get better it ended up being
myself and my best friend right ernie
smith eventually kyle singler who played
in the league for a number of years who
uh you know were the only white guys on
the team yeah and from from that point
on it just
became you know kind of part of who i am
what i'm about is that you know i knew
if i was gonna be the best i had to play
against the best and that happened to be
the case you know we're in such a hyper
masculine sport and it's both men and
women's like sports i really believe
that or it could be
you know you could work in finance you
could work at a fortune 500 company like
no matter what walk of life you're in
like withholding compassion does nobody
any good like you're more empathetic
you're more involved you're a better
listener like it creates community it
creates understanding so i mean that's
what i've learned i'm
again on the court outside of it i'm not
perfect at all i just hope like if i
could just help like one kid you know
early intervention get in there and say
listen the brain is changing so much
before behavior like if i can help that
that one kid listen
i'm good i help myself i help somebody
i'm living life out in the open i'm open
book i'm good well i think you've done
that i think uh what i thought was okay
well i'm gonna just deal with this for
this season and has been ongoing right
there are times where i i'm mr happy go
lucky to be honest some glass at full do
but i feel like
you know seeing you guys whether it's
you or demar deroza or dak prescott i
think more kids need to be
lifted up mentally
a sport is not end-all be all like we
sometimes we forget like it's weird as
an adult who's played in the pros
watching my son play and then watch the
other parents how they talk to their kid
you didn't you know you didn't do this
and i'm like hey hendrix did you get
sweaty i'm like awesome dude like
i don't care like are you enjoying your
time with your peers like are you
understanding the value of like
camaraderie sports should be
an outlet in a
in a place where
people can grow and not a place where
you're supposed to tuck your feelings
away
but something awesome has happened and
you see our whole lineup when i say hour
i mean
you are now part of the chosen family so
let's talk about like when did you get
into wine why did you want to get into
wine with me and with us at chosen you
know i grew up just outside of portland
oregon and obviously if you've been to
dundee hills willamette valley so on and
so forth in that region it's obviously
become more recognized as a place where
wine and that culture is continuing to
grow but when i was growing up
you know it was all pinot and shard
grapes so that's what i was first
introduced to and it wasn't until my
third or fourth year in the league i
mean i came in at 19 years old starting
my rookie season at 20. but
yeah my wine journey continued really
through my aunt on my dad's side
who introduced me to napa cabs so she
introduced me to a lot of california
grapes primarily being calves so i
initially just started drinking a lot of
cab and i think really in
2015-16 we started drinking that but
then you came on the team yeah
we started bringing new bottles we
started bringing different syrahs we
just started bringing different pinots
chardonnays all across the board yeah
it's going old world new world exactly
gracious and i think that opened me up
to understanding that okay the more i
know the more i realize i don't know but
boy i love this this is like you said a
connector for so many people we would
start bringing it on the plane and think
yo why aren't you giving me a glass why
can't i have a red cup and drink this
and we weren't snooting but we weren't
snobby about it at all then we would go
to dinner oh gosh we would order more
bottles no
and you said it funny like you would do
something you know super obscure
something different
you know i would bring obviously what i
love which is mostly like cabs and stuff
that was heavy at the time maybe some
pinots here and there that created a
culture with us i think outside of maybe
mello and a couple other players that
that culture of wine wasn't quite there
yet until honestly i think we took it
over the top and started it yeah this
has been a long time coming we talked
about it before i retired you know we
sat next to each other on the plane if
if we wanted to start a wine brand first
of all obviously do it in portland
there's a storytelling component there
there's a family component there like
what would we name it so we started
going through and listing out different
stuff you know your parties at the end
of the year were all based around wine
brought everybody together collectively
was super cool and i loved what yourself
jake chase
visiting longalo visiting that area and
starting chosen family i just you guys
were doing something different that i
wanted to be a part of it's funny we're
sitting here drinking wine because that
that all started oh
once you got there and i'm talking about
oh it started yeah we didn't realize
exactly what we had what we had was so
special like i look back and and i think
when you reach the pinnacle when you
when you're at the top you want that
it's it's like watching the last it's
like a drug yeah you want that you want
that every single year so to come from a
situation like you were to come into
that and win a champion it's
life-changing oh for sure it was like
it's a life-changing experience we were
the most talented
underachieving
regular season team of all time oh
easily without question we didn't care
until the playoffs did not care no we
would lose games and be like
honestly we were we we were we were days
of our lives we had so many story lines
we thrived under chaos but when it came
time
we had fun and we had the best like it
was the best i talked to richard about
it last night best years of my life like
we have our group chat we talk every day
every day every single day my memories
of cleveland were so vivid yeah right
and obviously we won but like i've never
been so locked in with a team to where
it was like we like loved each other mo
williams literally left
and nobody knew where he went and then
came back and played in game five of the
nba finals and was important to us dante
jones played in the finals like i
remember vividly coach going dante i
need you and he rips his stuff off he
hasn't played a minute dante jones
mental health right it has taken off and
you have been the face like you are the
front of the train of that so
tell me what inspired you to be the face
of this and then why you are the way you
are yeah well i mean first of all it
goes back to
really my childhood and hiding it for i
mean really until i was 29 years old and
that was 2017 right not exposing it
actually till until 2018 march of that
year
and it's funny you're such a huge part
of it and you know this and a lot of
people don't is that
you know there were a lot of pillars
that had fallen in my life personally
whether it be my family
friends
uh you know relationship business
i started self-medicating i started
you know getting it extremely dark um
the game was taken away from me from
uh injury perspective i broke in my my
left hand in a game in um detroit
yeah a lot of people didn't know what
was going on so i had teammates and uh
you know people turn on me and and call
me out and i wasn't ready to expose
myself at that level yet
and then all-star came around and
parkland florida happened
and you know there are rumblings at
all-star that were going on of of
certain people trying to
you know speak about me and my mental
health and i said okay
now i need to
tell my story i don't want anybody else
to tell my story i need to take this
into my own hands
like i'm afraid i'm afraid of how people
are going to react
how it's going to affect my livelihood
what people are going to think what my
best friends are going to think but
don't even know what the hell i'm going
through so
you know that that led me up to to that
point i didn't i didn't pull back the
curtain that much but enough to people
to look inside and say like everybody's
going through something
and us athletes are no different like
success is not immune to depression this
thing doesn't discriminate look at the
numbers especially coming out of this
time too the last 12 to 14 months it's
just when you see death for real or when
you deal with that or when you're in
that place
you can't
you can't justify putting your energy
into a game because understand yeah i
can't fight how i feel different
contacts but it was
a similar feeling yeah that
summer was very very very dark for me
yeah i had people literally saying like
don't take your life this summer yeah
yeah and that was that was crazy to me
yeah to hear that because i'm thinking
like maybe i have blinders on like maybe
i'm not seeing what these people are
seeing so i really had to look myself in
the mirror had to look inward that that
summer
and work on myself but from then and
earlier that that year to where i am now
i feel like being able to to just
pay it forward be able to speak about it
for sure has been
you know amazing i think honestly
sharing your story not only empowers
yourself but as a way of paying it
forward for others i always say nothing
haunts us like the things we don't say
like
you you you have to leave it out that
you have to expose it in some way i'm
not saying you have to do it publicly
but it's amazing how freeing that can be
the game is do you know your best friend
kevin what is my favorite city to play
in
i'll be honest i don't even know what
yes phoenix top three okay one one do
you like chicago nope do you like
new york city this is not how the game
works okay
um you can't say cleveland's too obvious
uh
los angeles yeah
boom channing frye what uh breed of dog
do i have
oh vestry is a visla there you go i hate
that [ __ ] dog what is the one thing
that makes a good party a cheese platter
a [ __ ] cheese platter got a hit right
if it is not local sourced honey
i'm not working with you it's got to be
the bee's knees
are we hearing that in the background
uh what is my pre-game ritual oh this is
impossible you drink your beet juice you
take your little peanut butter jelly
thing you get rid of everything that's
sweaty you go through six pair of socks
two jerseys two pants you switch all
your stuff up because you're sweating
you used to do these stretches and knees
stretches for at least 20 minutes
stretches eldos
yeah so yes or no am i right or wrong
put some speck on my name
kevin how old are my kids oh my god
hendrix is 11 10. close margot is
seven
nine close
roxie is
four yep okay lennox is
three yep okay shaniqua is shut up okay
what is a
niche item that i love to collect
oh
okay this is like three separate things
so if you get even one of them i'll be
surprised don't you have a navajo rug
in your house oh yeah that's actually
one yeah and number two would be trading
cards and number three
would be
uh
vintage patches vintage patches i know
you like patches i didn't know if they
were vintage no but like the rocks and
stuff that was pretty impressive right i
do i have really good memory about
things that don't matter what is my
favorite thing to order to eat
[Music]
i don't know so if i could eat one food
forever what would it be um
one food it's a burrito but oh a hundred
percent i how i miss that i'll never
know damn you can wrap anything what is
one food that i hate
oh cucumbers you're allergic
kevin this season
where was chosen's first bottle made
dundee hills
wow you even went with the ava but yes
loglow estate dundee hills go ahead
oh that was that was the last question
thank you guys for another episode
this has been
amazing to say the least i'm glad we
could do it in person
uh my bff
kevin love which means i'm fourth thank
you for oh yeah a lot of ads
uh thank you for coming to full body
[Music]
how did you scam your way into the show
i'm [ __ ] chatting frog